ama yaşlı durumda
[Müzik]
Bence
ve bizim tarihimiz var
Y
o
bitmiş
[Müzik]
üzgün
son
onun ölümü
Sen benim içinsin
iyi o ne
ilgili
aynı
Evet
farzedelim
[Müzik]
Ey
Uluslararası
çok
[Müzik]
bir sürü sefalet gibi
asla
Y
D
canlı bir şekilde
[Müzik]
meditasyon
herkes
[Müzik]
betis'e
sensiz
Gerçekler
Y
birçoğundan
Böyle
Y
[Müzik]
kullanarak
ve
Ey
Ancak
ile
benim için
[Müzik]
sonra aşağıdakiler
de
ayy
25 10 yapım aşamasında
iyi
bunun gibi
açıklasa da
[Müzik]
veya
sağlıklı yemeğin
Böyle
Bence
sağa
Ancak
Y
Evet evet
Ancak
Y
Evet
ve şimdi
bu bir dil
bir
Ama değil
[Müzik]
al ve oku bana bu site için şunu söylüyor
Şili'de
Hadi gidelim
[Müzik]
asla
Merhaba
[Müzik]
Y
Evet
ama içgüdü
gece yarısı geri geliyor
ve eğer varsa
o
Ey
önemli göğüslere girmek
mutlu
gülden ayırt etmez
onunla
Y
[Müzik]
çok parlak
Y
Ne
[Müzik]
iki öğleden sonra ve hala
veya
Hayır
[Müzik]
Çinliler
Bir kriz
[Müzik]
çok akıllıca bir hata yapıyor
Y
guillen
ve teslim edilir
genç bir adam olarak ve taklit edilmelidir
gün
[Müzik]
fakir olmak
Evet
[Müzik]
ve hayati olmak
bir iletişim kağıdı
çok iyi
H
[Müzik]
Alanda
diğerleri
Evet
ve insan parası
[Müzik]
görelim
senin büyükannen
Y
meyve olduğumuz gibi
senin tarafında olacağım
[Müzik]
Bununla
Evet
Y
Ancak
yaz geceleri
dünyada büyük
[Müzik]
beyler açıkça var
daha fazlası için
iyi evet
içeri
Y
hemen göze çarpmayan
[Müzik]
beni terk ediyorlar
yaban mersini
Acı biber
bakmak
artı
ya da değil
[Müzik]
D
Y
vardım
ve diğerleri
Evet
ile
ve bu yıllarda
[Müzik]
hayır
hepsi dağınık
Evet evet
tüm hayatım boyunca
Y
[Müzik]
oradaki çocuk bilmiyorlardı
Ey
Deniz
[Müzik]
o gitmek zorunda
köylü
Halloldu
Evet
son yıllar mı
nokta
H
[Müzik]
eğer o egzersizi yaparsak
ama evet kızlar
o zaman varırız
Y
Ben
kombine
konuştuklarında
[Müzik]
ve sen
ve çok
ama orada
insanlardan dakikalar önce
Evet
olmalıdır
Y
[Müzik]
bir
ve yollarına geri dön
[Müzik]
dır-dir
Y
Bence
İstiyorum
ve eğer sahipsek
senin
[Müzik]
bana göre
bugün televizyonda
D
meyve bahçesi
[Müzik]
Ben
turuncu imparatorluğun birçoğu var
[Müzik]
sahip olmak
Ben
Ancak
[Müzik]
nasılsın
sahiptim
çok iyi hepimiz
olsa bile
dj'ler
aynısı
şimdi
önünde
Mitchell
nerede
[Müzik]
doğrusu
bağlantı kuracak olan sadece 2007'den değil
bana göre
ve dakikalar içinde bana geliyorlar
[Müzik]
Y
yani bile değil
[Müzik]
ek olarak
şehir
[Müzik]
çok